[Music]
one big pitfall that I see is that it's
problematic if you are not positioned to
take advantage of luck when a lucky
event comes your way so people who are
lucky positioned themselves so that when
something happens that they can take
advantage of they can grasp that
opportunity and make the most of it this
comes back to this idea of lucky events
being different from lucky outcomes
lucky events can happen to a lot of
people but only some people in that
population might be in a position to
actually capitalize on those lucky
events and create a lucky outcome for
themselves for instance imagine the
example of a lottery rip winner the
focus is on having the winning lottery
ticket but what really matters and what
people talk about is the ability to
spend that ticket so if the person has
the winning ticket but loses it they
don't consider themselves very lucky
usually but the person who gains the
winnings from the lottery ticket and who
uses them in productive ways is seen as
lucky there's an old Chinese poem about
lucky or not lucky and it illustrates
how different different outcomes in Our
Lives can have consequences that affect
us detrimental er positively so many
areas of life where we think we might be
lucky might lead the consequences that
aren't lucky and sometimes things that
happen to us or we think we're not lucky
actually leads to an abundance of luck
you take the example of a lottery winner
for instance you look at lottery winners
sometimes the lottery winning actually
destroys their life and so the question
was the lottery winning the lottery a
lucky event or not well it depends on
the outcome it depends on how well luck
is used to create other luck going
forward
one of the most interesting things I
found when we were looking at luck from
a scientific point of view has to do
with how a very small advantage can can
grow over time when it's shared so if
you share lucky a lucky event or the
outcome of a lucky event with others who
are likely to have future contact with
you that luck is likely to grow and
back to you the most selfish thing a
lucky person can do is to share their
luck with other people and when you're
suited to many many opportunities by
definition you can't pursue and you
can't take all of them but what do you
do with them the best thing to do is to
share those opportunities with other
people that you know who could use those
opportunities and as you share them
you're creating a bond and the
preconditions for pro-social activity to
happen in the future
lucky people almost always share their
luck with other people and it comes back
to benefit them in great ways and
there's a saying we have that you don't
get lucky by sitting home watching TV
you get lucky about being out there by
talking with people by interacting with
them and engaging with them letting them
know what excites you and letting them
know how your talents might be able to
help them there are a lot of social
butterflies out there and they might be
working really hard behind the scenes to
make more luck and when the work happens
to them they say well I was just lucky
there was a lucky person and it happens
to me but of course when you look more
closely many of the times they're just
prepared in a much better way they're
positioning themselves well and they're
able to avail themselves the more
possibility than the others who are not
quite as engaged
[Music]